They must goes into a podiatrist's
office and the podiatry side that says,
what's the problem?
And the mom says,
Where do I begin?
Man?
Norm Mcdonald is one of those comedians
who functions as a litmus test for
people's sense of humor.
If you find norm hilarious,
for example,
I know that your sense of humor and mine
are probably pretty similar.
Norm splits people and if he does so
more than most,
I think it's because his vision of
comedy is unflinching unflinchingly
devoted to what he finds funny,
which means that he won't ever try to
modify his work to appease an audience.
Of course,
this has led to what I think is the
mistaken notion,
one that you often see in youtube
comments that norm just doesn't care
what people think
because I go to work for a gregory,
a linen,
which honestly I don't even know what
I'm doing anymore.
I don't even know if Gregory Olin
Yvette's knows.
He only knows that he has power over me
and that seems to bring up
in us.
I think norm cares deeply about his
audiences.
He wouldn't spend thousands of hours
honing his material if you didn't want
to make people laugh.
He just doesn't let the audience dictate
the direction of this work.
He doesn't pander.
In fact,
during his time at snl as the host of
weekend update,
he often did the exact opposite norms,
distaste for performing in front of an
audience that was essentially forced to
laugh,
urged him to tell jokes that would shock
them into silence or gasps.
A decade before Ricky Gervais' made a
splash by making fun of celebrities at
the Golden Globes norm hosted the sps
with jokes.
Hey,
began the first defensive player to win
the heisman trophy,
and congratulations,
Charles.
That is something that no one can ever
take away from you unless you kill your
wife later,
in which case
take bravery.
It takes dedication.
At night I sometimes wake up and I
turned to some old lady in my bed that's
on my arm,
a lady that I once loved duck.
I don't know where to turn to my
youngest Alexandria.
She fell in the.
In the,
in the cold of last year.
Norms,
dedication to the craft is almost
inhuman and so much of it is unseen.
He's one of the smartest,
well-read people in stand up
particularly well read in Russian
literature.
If you couldn't tell by the names that
he's making up in the mouth joke,
and yet his whole act is predicated on
this folksy,
dopey innocence.
He's like that magician from the
prestige who devotes his whole life to a
character just to pull off a great
trick.
This
he's the truth.
This is one owner can detect this total
devotion to his own self sacrifice at my
other boy.
This is the hardest pill to swallow my
after boy,
Greg Arrow.
Then a little
I no longer love him,
not trying to pull off tricks.
Of course he's trying to pull off jokes,
a joke with a premise and the punchline,
it's kind of funny.
Norm was known for his super short jokes
during this weekend update period and
now he's known for these super long
rambling jokes that he often tells on
late show appearances.
It's these longer jokes which bear a
resemblance to shaggy dog stories that
often get him labeled as an anti comic
or a medical clinic,
but he strongly insists that he is
neither of these things in interviews.
Norm rejects anything that sees itself
as above comedy.
Looking down on it either to ridicule or
to comment.
His jokes always have punchlines.
Punchlines.
That makes sense.
Whether or not you think they're funny,
he can deliver a joke quickly.
Hey,
you know the funniest part of doing an
office Congo line.
When you look back and realize they're
doing it alone and you're not in an
office,
you're in a psychiatric hospital where
he can string out punchlines like pearls
on a wire across a long story.
This joke from his special me doing
standup is 12 minutes long.
Seems like there's too much news because
now they have 24 hour news.
Now,
when I was a young boy,
the news was half a hour.
That was the whole.
It starts by talking about 24 hour news
and eventually makes his way to a
detailed description of how he would
murder someone and the progression.
It's completely natural.
I would take her body to the woods and
barrier in a very,
very,
very deep grave along the way.
There was plenty of punchlines to laugh
at and as things get crazier,
you get drawn into a kind of.
A lady has vanished cetera.
Fat.
I'm Kinda happy it's Janice and not
somebody I know to meet her one day.
That would be a lot of fuck.
I forgot.
She vanished time.
They will find you in a shallow grave.
Serial killers are supposed to be so
shrewd and cunning and you know,
but then when it comes time for the
grave,
it'll hasty.
You know,
what I would do is I would like,
I would look at the lay,
I would select a lady and then I would
follow her habits.
You understand what I'm saying?
What would I be a holding in my right
hand in the parking lot,
but a cheese sandwich.
I got a whole fucking van full of,
um,
get in there and I would do that thing
that makes me feel like God.
And then I would take her body to the
woods and barrier in a very,
very,
very deep brave,
which is have this joke is there if you
want to look for it,
the word choices,
the freezing.
It's all precisely chosen,
but norm doesn't call attention to his
own intelligence.
The punchlines just appear like flashes
of light.
If only the cowardice was stronger than
perhaps grabs I couldn't bring myself to
reach over to that cocked and loaded gun
that lays on the bed.
And then this hellish facade,
one
constellation of comedy greats.
Norm is among the least famous,
but he's also one of the most
underrated.
That's because standup was never a
stepping stone for him to greater
success or greater fame,
but an end in itself,
an art to perfect is kind of comedy is
built to last like a low frequency noise
that might not demand the same kind of
attention is high pitch sounds,
but we'll travel a much greater distance
in the end.
Enormous jokes are the ones you'll
remember latent to your life.
The ones will all be telling for years
to come because they're construction is
sophisticated,
but their delivery is easy to
understand.
Getting that balance exactly right is
the work of an entire career,
but norm mcdonald more than anyone else
knows that a long winding journey is
okay.
As long as the payoff is worth it.
It says dark because I feel like a
spider even though I have a ma just
barely hanging on to my web with
everlasting fire underneath me,
I'm not feeling good and so the mice,
the director says,
math,
man,
you're a troubled but you shouldn't be
seeing a psychiatrist.
Why on earth did you come here?
And then the Ma said,
because the light was on,
everybody's
eating so much for watching my episode
on norm.
I really love his comedy.
Make sure you subscribe to this channel.
If you want to see more videos like this
every week or so,
and subscribe to norms,
youtube channel at Norm Mcdonald,
you can find it.
If you just type that in,
repost his podcasts and live show and
this episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a really easy process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from.
That makes the process so easy and
simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is super,
super easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.